[Musique]
[Rires]
olian dans les haau de Saint-Joseph
Aline folio fabrique encore des chapeaux
avec les feuilles du vétivvert cette
plante don l'huile essentiellerait des
racines est un réputé fixateur de parfum
a vécu ses plus belles années et
pourtant loin de l'agitation citadine
encore quelques personnes dont Aline
avec ses chapeaux entretiennent l'espoir
de sauvegarder une parcelle de notre
patrimoine ça oui et ben me fait
bouillir puis me fait chcher blanchi et
ça là ça plus dur d'accord ben me
ramasse les feuilles comme ça me donne à
ma fille pour aller eniller ses chaise
ah d'accord avec le vê même al il la
chaise il finit rien dans le V oui la
racine ça c'est la racine maintenant B n
plus rien
d'accord comment reconnaître quand c'est
T b c'est pas la couleur des feuilles ah
ben on connait VO pas tu vois pas
différence ah oui d'accord oui ça n pas
bon alors ça trop ah non ça est bon pour
la chaise d'accord voilà c'est ça comme
ça voilà il il reconnait hein voilà
c'est ça ça les bon pour c'est ça voilà
ça il blanchit mieux que ça aussi oui le
fait que les tendes il blanchit plus
vite ou oui et par les cœur d'accord et
là-bas il blanchit bien aussi là mais le
bout de çae un petit peu bleu mais pour
de chaise bon quand même et pour les
chaises il faut faire bouillir aussi ah
oui oui hein
ou sin BR
d'accord et
là
comm
ah ou fait pas
d'accord à
côé cé un côté avant et l'utre côté
après alors
préarationorsprend
mie Rapp depuis quel ge la commence
ch commenc
avant ou com je F pas
maisis
se ta maman elle faisit
alorsociationou
combien de temps l' pris pour sécher ça
ben ça ça pris 3 jours à peu près oui ça
c'est à peu près
pareil différence de couleur quand même
parce que ça c'est depuis l'année
dernière oui et ça c'est cette année
d'accord voilà
et c'estàdire qu' m occupé ça ça chez R
max et ben le temps j'étais pas trop
beau et là le temps c'est beau alors là
il est plus joli d'cord ah oui d'accord
il fallait cueillir en plein beout temps
alors oui c'est comme ça V c'est
ça des fois si mais ça faire avec
ça pas sera une couleur différent c'est
tout oui pas jaune mais fa lu mettre un
brun pour aider C petit travail il peut
faire avec on peut mélanger les les les
pailles là oui il peut mélanger mais
bien pas trop parce que TR ça la
différence moi c'est Mo il fait le
travail moi mais différent non au niveau
de la de la rigidité peut-être non parce
que fait un chapeau comme ça toute seule
là les gens ils connais pas oui c'est
moi connais diff c'est qui conna
voilà combien d'Ur par jour travaille de
fetiv comme ça benah il dépend fait un
petit peu mon travail le matin puis là
vous me dit si Mo un petit peu libre ben
merci maîesse ou bien il fait un peu le
soir est-ce que Arve des jeunes qui
vient voir comme ça montre à comment il
fait
chapau les jeun plus
travailler c'est par va fin que dans le
coin là y a vous qui
travaillez que moi la des gre peut-être
quelqu'uno
une mais
sinon que moi mainten et pourquoi ça
c'est
Paso c'est une spécialité du quartier ou
pas ça oui ben ici c'était il faut dire
de mon quartier là c'était Ren V oui
mais qu la nu après et ben le vê au fur
à mesure a fini encore beaucoup de champ
de vtist là non plusci n plus du tout
que René
max pe lui par
lu Comment lui tient pour pour son
travail d'accord mais sinon on a plus à
qu a disparu comme ça ben je sais pas je
pas si les gens plus V le travail ou
bien peut-être gagner plus assz dedans
il connait pas trop aussi moi parce que
moi dans mon temps m'a fait jusqu'à
tempant mon mari n de travailler m'a
fait est-ce qu'on a travaillé dans les
champs de V oui oui m' graté V m' plter
V il Metz l'engra dedans aussi et mon
mari fouillé ça c'est avant la machine
ou lui fouiller les grosses gobbes comme
ça et moi pas derri pour Mo secouer oui
et puis il fallaitrer nos bras la
terille arrivé jusque là pour bien tirer
le dessous parce le dessous n'a plus
l'essence que le dessus d'accord et vous
mettre quel style de chapeau commenti
oui ça va com ça ma bans B un petit
pe dit marchandise par N pas de valeur
mais si sinon qui ça va vter très joli
qu je soleil parce que a une tête là ça
la pluie oui mais c elle reçoit pas ah
bon elle supporte pas
supporte pas du tout ah
[Musique]
d'acc ce CHL il appartient à René max
qu'on appelle
tiabri amicalement c'est un jeune bah
oui pourquoi lui il est resté dans le V
est que lu a dit pourquoi lui ça l'
jamais parler sais pas peut-être lu aime
ça et et ben doit sentir lui un peu
libre aussi pour faire son travail lui
est libre est que c'est pas plutôt
l'envie de faire survivre le V bah oui
c'est ça aussi parce que B il reste que
lui ici en
[Musique]
hautin et on trouve c'est c'est une
bonne racine est joli là oui c'est joli
c'est grand sent bon bien sû il sont
mais ça c'est de Racine neuve un an il
est bon là qu' a 2 an s pu pareil la
deuxème étape après ça c'est quoi après
benah quand il fait le V quand il fait
Cu là comme ça c'est fait Cu directement
comme ça d'accord ça oui et ben lu fait
dans la machine ah oui très bien et ça
c'est pour lui faire c'est petit paquet
les autres choses ça qui est blanc là
d'accord voilà ok mais comme ça il fait
cuire comme mon mari il faisait cuire là
son linge ti sur lui là sentit ça même
ilavait la première fois il sentait pas
l'odeur oui
jamais et ça c'est la seule machine
authentique qui reste dans l'île alors
d'accordou c'est ça oui ça c'est une
machine V ver oui que navait pu à la
Réunion n avait tous les morceauxcord
oui René max l'a ramassé dans sur tous
les vieilles machines oui et puis lu de
Moné une c'est une authentique alors
voilà d'accord voilà et ben c'est la
seule qui reste la machine au bois et là
c'est il fait cuire au feu de bois oui
feu de bois d'accord c'est la seule qui
reste à la Réunion oui d'accord et pour
la cuisson il faut prendre combien de
temps au feu de bois comme ça 2 jours
jours de jours et puis une nuit he oui
au moins et qui c'est qui s'occupe de la
cuisson lui-même ben oui c'est René max
il reste sur place il fait cuire
ouais président
gouvernement
c'est des petites bottes de racine de V
ver est prêt à vendre ça oui les gens
achètent ça pourquoi pour mettre un les
insects pour mettre dans l' d'accord oui
le de en le linge oui
pu ins
d'accord mais le de il reste jusqu'à
combien de
temps moi il reste longtemps plus d'un
an plus d'un an ou ah oui dans quand
renfermé oui ouais c'est quand est all
[Musique]
Mo quel avenir vous donne au vê ver à la
Réunion àine quel avenir ben moi trou
trouve mais un bon travail dire que
c'est les jeunes qui veent plus faire il
g plus il dit gen danser mais et j' pas
resté aussi le vrai problème pour
c'estim aim faire ça ou qu on regrette
le plus puisque apparemment on a plus
beaucoup de champ dans l'île non ben
mais regrette parce que M trouve que
tous ces ch si je vou travailler B je
travail d'accord mais TR ça est-ce qu'il
est facile pour planter le V ver au
départ même au départ oui pour plter
facile oui facile
planter même pour gratter pas difficile
non plus mais c'est
après en fait c'est le travail c'est le
travail de la terre en fait qui
intéresse plus les jeunes aujourd'hui
alors
voilà disons peut-être
aussi dit comme si comme a il gagne
moins que longtemps longtemps il devait
pas gagner plus que ça mais nous c'était
ça notre vie il fallait nous tirer n
manger làdedans d'accord voilà on obligé
de faire et maintenant ben plus pareil
les chôeur il gagne gagne ça gagne
l'autre les parents les comment les
parents les retraité beaucoup il fitussi
donc ça veut dire que les parents les
parents la pasaton transmis aux enfants
cette passion là oui mais les enfants
pas voulu non plus tuas pas voulu non
plus Aline folio continue ainsi à
perpétuer la tradition en attendant une
hypothétique
[Musique]
relève